ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen es
ist der Morgen des 24 Februar 2022
Raketen auf Kiel vor einem Jahr
geschieht was viele trotz aller
Warnungen nicht für möglich gehalten
hatten Russland greift die Ukraine an
erstmals seit langem herrscht wieder
Krieg mitten in Europa und damit tot
Leid Zerstörung Frieden ist bis heute
nicht in Sicht
wir nehmen diesen Jahrestag zum Anlass
um mit den Leuten zu sprechen die dieser
Krieg vor allem betrifft die vor allem
unter diesem Krieg leiden in der Sendung
haben wir später eine Ärztin aus harkev
die berichtet wie sie den Beginn der
Angriffe erlebt hat und wie es ihr heute
geht wir bemühen uns außerdem um eine
militärische Einschätzung dazu haben wir
den ehemaligen Nato-General Egon Rams
eingeladen der ja schon oft hier in der
Sendung war und alles was ihr viel von
ihm wissen wollt schreibt gerne in die
Kommentare oder per Mail an die
eingeblendete E-Mail-Adresse
für uns hier ist es schwer vorstellbar
was das bedeutet wenn dein Land
plötzlich im Krieg ist wenn bombenfallen
wenn nichts mehr so ist wie es vorher
war die Ukrainerin Valeria shashinock
hat von Tag eins an auf ihre ganz eigene
Art über tiktok Millionen auf der ganzen
Welt gezeigt was es bedeutet im Krieg zu
sein und wie sich der Alltag für sie
verändert hat
[Musik]
mit ihrem ganz eigenen Stil den
Schrecken des Krieges mit Humor und
Sarkasmus darzustellen ist sie zu den
bekanntesten ukrainischen tiktokerinnen
geworden weileria schascheock lebt
inzwischen in London und von dort ist
sie uns zugeschaltet hallo Frau
schaschek
[Musik]
guten Abend ich begrüße auch alle vielen
Dank für die Einladung
wie erinnern sie sich an den Beginn
dieses Krieges an den Tag vor dem
Kriegsbeginn vor einem Jahr und dann als
der Krieg ausbrach
[Musik]
mein 23 Februar war ein ganz
gewöhnlicher Tag aber alle waren
angespannt man hatte Angst vor der
Invasion das was am 24 Februar erfolgte
überraschte viele Menschen
aber das war ein ziemlich verbreiteter
ein ziemlich verbreitetes Thema ich habe
mir am 23 februar eine Kamera gekauft
und als ich am 24 Februar aufwachte kam
meine Mutter ins Zimmer und meinte
valiere
da hat wahrscheinlich der Krieg begonnen
in Kiew finden Bombardements statt
und das nicht nur in Kiew sondern auch
in der Region in der sie gelebt haben
wir schauen uns das gerade mal an
chennier ist ihre Heimatstadt wir haben
eine Karte damit wir ungefähr eine
Vorstellung haben wo das liegt das ist
im Nordosten oder im Norden des Landes
sehen wir hier nahe der Grenze zu
Russland und Belarus und hier ist die
russische Armee in den ersten
Kriegstagen tief ins Land eingedrungen
mit gewaltiger Artillerie haben die
Soldaten hier ganze Städte in Schutt und
Asche gelegt und auch schene ist massiv
zerstört worden sie haben das gefilmt
sie haben das dokumentiert über tiktok
und das schauen wir uns auch noch mal an
[Musik]
wir müssen noch mal versuchen uns
irgendwie das uns irgendwie in sie rein
zu versetzen wir sehen dieses Leben im
Bunker was sie da schildern 17 Tage lang
waren sie ja in einem Schutzraum und sie
machen das auf eine witzige
leichtfertige Art mit viel Humor und das
kriegt man irgendwie nicht zusammen mit
den massiven Zerstörungen und der Angst
die man sicherlich auch in dem Moment
haben gehabt hat können Sie uns
beschreiben wie das war und was sie dazu
gebracht hat das so darzustellen warum
das Mittel des Humors warum ist das so
wichtig
ich habe den Krieg so dokumentiert wie
ich das wahrgenommen habe am Anfang
konnte ich nur schwer nachvollziehen was
eigentlich ablief
mein Sinn für Humor ist mein
Schutzmittel
und das erste Video das sehr beliebt
wurde war mit Witz gemacht aber
anschließend nutzte ich nicht nur Humor
sondern ich versuchte das alles unter
einen Hut zu bringen etwas Witziges
etwas informatives etwas
anderes ich habe präsentiert für meine
Mutter kocht wie man sich aufs Leben in
einem Bunker einstellt und so weiter ich
habe den Ausländern
gezeigt wie man im ukrainischen
Kulturkreis lebt
ich habe versucht das auf eine
vernünftige Art und Weise zu machen aber
ich bin sehr dankbar dass mir nichts
passiert ist ich weiß es gibt sehr viele
Menschen die im Bombenkeller bleiben
mussten wie sie von russischen Soldaten
gefoltert worden sind es gibt sehr viele
Menschen die ums Leben gekommen sind die
kein Zuhause haben mein Onkel hat nun
weder den Sohn der 18 Jahre alt war noch
sein eigenes zu Hause
ich bin am Leben geblieben aber was die
anderen Ukrainer erlebt haben ich will
gar nicht
behaupten dass ich ein schlechtes Leben
hatte ich weiß welches leiden andere
Ukrainer ertragen haben deshalb versuche
ich einfach zu schweigen
[Musik]
hier kommt ein Kommentar von einem User
mag Landsberg schreibt über Youtube wer
von uns kann sich den Horror vorstellen
wenn plötzlich Krieg in deiner Heimat
eindringt also hier in den Chats ist
auch sehr viel Verständnis und sehr viel
Mitgefühl für Sie und auch für die
Familien in der Ukraine ihre eigene
Familie ist ja jetzt zerrissen wenn ich
das richtig verstanden habe dann sind
sie in London ihre Eltern sind aber in
der Ukraine geblieben wie gehen Sie mit
dieser Situation jetzt um
[Musik]
meine Mutter und mein Vater sind in der
Tat in der Ukraine es tut mir sehr leid
dass sie nicht umziehen wollen aber ich
kann sie auch verstehen sie können kein
Englisch mein Vater hat ein Geschäft in
der Ukraine mein Vater hat eine Wohnung
in der Ukraine er hat alles was man
brauchen könnte er hat noch nicht so
viel Geld wie vor dem Krieg aber er ist
Ukraine warum sollte er dir Ukraine
verlassen
meine Mutter will das Land nicht ohne
ihren Ehemann verlassen dass es ihre
Wahl ich freue mich dass die beiden
zusammenhalten ich unterhalte mich
täglich mit meinen Eltern ich hatte es
schwer als ich die Ukraine verlassen
hatte da gab es Stromausfälle da gab es
keine Telefonverbindung ich möchte mir
Sorgen
und jennyche war innerhalb eines Monats
unter Besetzung und anschließend
verbesserte sich die Lage aber ich muss
sagen meine Mutter der Gesundheit war
ganz schlecht ich fühlte dauernd Angst
und ich wollte einfach die Augen zu
machen und in einer anderen Realität
aufwachen
ich war in der Ukraine vor ein paar
Monaten und ich habe mich mit meinen
Eltern getroffen
und das war wohl die beste Zeit dass ich
meine Eltern wieder sehen durfte
haben sie Angst um ihre Eltern
wissen sie das mag
komisch wirken aber ich bin mir sicher
meinen Eltern wird nichts Schlechtes
passieren die Ukraine wird bald den
Siegerinnen und wir werden bald feiern
ich bin zuversichtlich alles wird gut
ausgehen ich habe ein sehr gutes Gefühl
ein User fragt mit dem Blick in die
Zukunft Christian heißt der was erwarten
sie von der Zukunft und auch der Aspekt
wird ihre Generation je wieder mit
Russland zusammenleben können ist hier
die Frage
ich glaube man kann Beziehungen mit
Russland für immer vergessen das ist
unmöglich alles sind empört was die
Handlungen Russlands angeht hier der
Ukraine der sich respektiert
wenn er die Möglichkeit hätte dieses
Land von der Mappe auszuradieren so wäre
das ein schönes Geschenk
was war noch mal die erste Frage über
mein Schicksal
die Frage war wie sie sich die Zukunft
vorstellen wie sie sich die Zukunft
wünschen
das ist eine sehr komplexe Frage für
mich ich bin noch sehr jung ich habe
sehr viele Wünsche ich habe bis jetzt
eine rosarote Brille und ich habe den
Eindruck alles wird gut sein und ich
habe sogar Angst etwas zu planen ich
wünsche mir dass diese Krieg möglichst
bald zu Ende geht dass Russland als ein
Terrorist
ich möchte dass der Krieg zu Ende geht
und dass ich feiern und
tanzen kann dass ich die Ukraine mit
meinen
Landsleuten wieder aufbauen kann
sagt Valeria schascheock vielen Dank und
hier im Chat ist noch ein Kommentar den
ich Ihnen gerne mitgeben möchte ihr
optimismus ist lobenswert schreibt hier
ein User alles Gute für Sie und danke
dass Sie bei uns in der Sendung waren
Frau
damit verabschieden wir uns aus nach
London und machen hier weiter mit der
militärischen Expertise ich habe es
schon angekündigt und es war vor einem
Jahr so dass nicht nur viele Menschen
vor Ort sondern auch viele Osteuropa
Experten viele Wissenschaftler und
Politiker tatsächlich am Ende überrascht
waren als Wladimir Putin am 24 Februar
2022 die Ukraine über viel wie ging es
eigentlich einem hohen Militär der mit
seiner Expertise von Tag eins des
Krieges an hier im ZDF die Lage
eingeschätzt hat das möchten wir gerne
besprechen mit Egon Rams da ist er Herr
Rams sie sind Nato-General ade und damit
einer der ranghöchsten deutschen
Soldaten gewesen mit jahrelanger
Erfahrung im Führungsstab des Heeres und
der Streitkräfte sie waren am Tag als
der Krieg begann im ZDF spezialstudio
und haben auch viele O-Töne in allen
Sendungen an diesem Tag gegeben wie
erinnern Sie sich an diese Stunden
ja ich war vielleicht nicht ganz so
überrascht wie viele andere weil für
mich eigentlich der schlüsseltag der 21
Februar gewesen ist als Putin seine Show
abgezogen hat mit dem Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat seiner langen
geschichtsverfälschtenden Rede und
anschließend mit den beiden
separatistenführern aus dem Donbass dann
entsprechende Papiere unterzeichnet hat
an dem Abend kamen die Meldung dass sich
die ersten russischen Truppen in
Bewegung setzen man konnte zu dem
Zeitpunkt nicht sagen wann es passieren
würde aber es müsste den nächsten Tagen
passieren und es war dann der 24
trotzdem muss ich so ehrlich sein zu
sagen ich habe eigentlich bis zum
Schluss gehofft das Blut in diesem
Schritt nicht gehen würde dann lassen
Sie uns gemeinsam auf den Kriegsbeginn
schauen und auch noch mal auf ihre
Einschätzungen von damals Pablo sie hat
silalahi fast das zusammen er hat ins
Archiv geschaut
[Musik]
Donnerstag 24 Februar 2022 seit den
frühen Morgenstunden greifen russische
Truppen hunderte Ziele in der ganzen
Ukraine an
Luftalarm auch in Kiew die 3 Millionen
Stadt steht unter Beschuss
hier treffen die russischen Raketen
anders als von Moskau behauptet auch
zivile Wohngebiete
ich wohne gleich da drüben es war eine
unglaublich starke Explosion ich hatte
Panik und rannte nach draußen überall
Sirenen und die Alarmanlagen der Autos
die Menschen im ganzen Land versuchen
sich in Sicherheit zu bringen in den
Schächten der Metro oder am besten noch
außerhalb der Stadt auf den Straßen
riesige Staus viele schlagen sich zu Fuß
durch für die Ärzte beginnt ein
Dauereinsatz
am schlimmsten war für mich wohl der
erste Monat also der Zeitraum bis April
all unsere Ärzte und Krankenschwestern
sind dann ins Krankenhaus gezogen und
wir haben dort bis April übernachtet
also das heißt wir bleiben dauernd fort
[Musik]
spricht nur Stunden nach den Angriffen
den Menschen Mut zu man solle nicht in
Panik verfallen
neben den Luftangriffen attackiert
Russland die Ukraine gleich von vier
Seiten aus mit Bodentruppen auch aus
Richtung Belarus für Experten mit einem
bestimmten Ziel was mich überrascht hat
ist der Angriff aus Belarus raus
Richtung Norden das wird praktische
Kiew unmittelbar bedroht
doch Russland gelingt es nicht Kiew
einzunehmen in einem Jahr Krieg einen
Krieg der das Land und die Menschen
verändert hat
wir haben sie gerade noch mal gesehen
mit ihrer Einschätzung von vor einem
Jahr ist es das was sie am meisten
überrascht hatte
also ich glaube ähnlich wie die
ukrainische Seite die den Angriff mehr
aus dem Osten erwartet hatte ging es mir
damals auch ich war auch überrascht
darüber dass die Truppenteile der Russen
die vorher mit den weißrussischen
Truppenteilen Manöver durchgeführt
hatten praktisch aus bellhausen oder von
belarussischem Boden diesen Angriff
durchgeführt haben es gibt noch einen
weiteren überraschenden Faktor der mir
damals so klar nicht wahr das ist die
Tatsache gewesen dass auch der Angriff
von Süden spricht von der alten Krim aus
nach Nordwesten für die Russen relativ
große schnelle Erfolge gebracht hat
während der Angriff aus Norden auf Kiew
zu ja relativ schnell zum stehen
gekommen ist
bevor wir auf die frontverläufe nochmal
konkreter gucken muss ich hier in die
Chats blicken und sehe dass viele ihrer
Fans schon versammelt sind daran mag
Spielweg schreibt ich will ein Autogramm
von Egon Rams ich weiß nicht ob sie das
machen können sie sich ja vielleicht
während der Sendung im Verlauf der
Sendung noch überlegen dann schreibt
hier rum Egon Rams sehr gut und
krallikral schreibt Rams top top top
also ähm hier ist laufen auch viele
Fragen ein wir versuchen die im Laufe
der Sendung auch zu beantworten haben
aber lassen Sie uns kurz noch mal auf
die gerade von Ihnen beschriebenen Front
Verläufe gucken wir haben eine Karte
vorbereitet wie die Situation war vor
einem Jahr zu Kriegsbeginn und wir sehen
dass die russischen Truppen vor allem
tief ins Land eingedrungen sind
von Norden und herrniev und in die
Vororte hier sehen wir die Karte das ist
der 24.2 und die
in den Areale im Norden Osten und Süden
des Landes im Süden warens mikolaiw und
Mariupol im Osten war es rakev im Norden
chernief und die Vororte Kiews wie
gesagt und jetzt sehen wir heute
konzentrieren sich die Kämpfer auf den
Südosten des Landes hier noch mal in der
Wiederholung wie es vor einem Jahr war
und wie die Gebiete jetzt umkämpft sind
harams
wie würden sie beschreiben was ist in
diesem einen ja passiert wie lässt sich
das Zusammenfassen
also das geht natürlich jetzt nur ich
sage das mal in großen Sprüngen nach dem
Beginn des russischen Angriffs am 24.2
hatten die Russen offensichtlich die
Absicht über den Süden von der Halbinsel
Krim und dem Norden auf Kiew zuzustoßen
und möglicherweise damit die Ukraine
gleich von Anfang an zu teilen
im Norden sind die Ukrainer wie im Süden
von dem Angriff überrascht worden weil
die ukrainische Seite offensichtlich den
Schwerpunkt im Osten erwartet hatte wo
er nicht gelegen hat nachdem der Angriff
Richtung Kiew dann im Laufe des März
April zum Stillstand gekommen war
hat praktisch Russland die Truppenteile
die im Norden eingesetzt waren
umgruppiert und zur neuen
Schwerpunktbildung im Osten genutzt was
auch dann relativ erfolgreich war
Vorstoß fast bis nach jagdf oder bis
nach jakiefer im Süden deutlich über den
jepper hinweg nach Nordwesten in
nordwestlicher Richtung auch erfolgreich
angegriffen während der Angriff im Osten
sehr langsam nur voran kam wir erinnern
uns etwa Mitte des Jahres waren Namen
wie es wäre dann jetzt oder Lucy chansk
Namen von Städten die sehr heiß und sehr
stark umkämpft waren und wir hatten dann
zum Herbst hin hatten wir einen gewissen
Wendepunkt durch die Tatsache dass auch
die Ukraine ihre Kräfte umgruppiert
hatte und dann insbesondere von chakiv
aus Gegenangriffe in südöstlicher und
östlicher Richtung gestartet haben die
ich sag das mal vorsichtig auch aufgrund
der verbesserten Bewaffnung aufgrund
westlicher Waffenlieferung und
dergleichen mehr dann relativ
erfolgreich waren im September Oktober
kam dann das freikämpfen von
unten im Süden bis an den depper an so
dass das westliche in Jever Ufer wieder
vollständig in der Hand in der Ukrainer
war ich glaube dass die russische Seite
sich einen derartigen gefechtsverlauf
von Seiten der ukrainische Streitkräfte
die ja immer durch die Bevölkerung sehr
intensiv unterstützt wurden so nicht
gesehen und so nicht erwartet hat
zurzeit haben wir alle etwas andere
Situation im Raum bachmut und
Boulevard finden Kämpfe intensivste
Kämpfe statt sie wissen dass manche
Leute dieses mit den Kämpfen vom Verdon
im Ersten Weltkrieg vergleichen was ich
anders sehe und anders bewährte aber das
ist ein anderes Thema
wichtig ist in meinen Augen dass das
Momentum was die Ukrainer bei den
Gegenangriffen im Süden Stichwort Person
und von chakiff nach Osten entwickelt
haben
erhalten geblieben wäre dass es nicht
der Fall wahrscheinlich auch wieder weil
in keiner dafür den notwendigen Waffen
gefehlt haben und es muss uns aus dem
Westen und auch genug Rheinland darum
gehen dieses Momentum für ihre
Gegenangriffe wieder zu gewinnen und
dann weiter zu versuchen die Russen aus
dem besetzten Gebieten zu vertreiben
damit haben sie zwei Fragen schon zum
Teil beantwortet die ich hier sehe mag
Spielweg hat über Youtube gefragt können
Sie abschätzen wie lange sich das noch
zieht und wie sieht die Lage derzeit an
den Brennpunkten bachmut herson solle da
aus und Ronny Lux hat auch über Youtube
gefragt wird die Ukraine die nächste
Offensive im Süden durchführen möchten
Sie auf beides auch wenn sie es gerade
schon mal angerissen haben noch mal kurz
eingehen
also das ist ein bisschen über das was
ich gesagt habe hinaus ich gehe davon
aus dass die Ukraine ein Interesse daran
hat im Osten den Angriff den
Gegenangriff sage ich richtigerweise in
die besetzten Bereiche wieder
aufzunehmen und erfolgreich vorzuführen
dafür braucht sie die entsprechenden
Waffen und die entsprechende
Unterstützung aus dem Westen alleine
kann die Ukraine das nicht realisieren
weil sie weder hinreichend Waffen noch
Munition hat und im Süden sehe ich im
Augenblick den den jepper als eine Art
Trennungslinie zwischen den zwischen den
ukrainischen Truppen und den russischen
Truppen und ich kann zurzeit keine
Vorhersage machen und möchte auch nicht
spekulieren wann die Ukraine
möglicherweise die Absicht haben den in
jepper dort zu überschreiten und dann
möglicherweise weiter nach Südosten das
heißt in Richtung Krim vorzustoßen die
Absicht werden sie haben auf lange Sicht
aber das bedarf dann auch mit der
Überwindung dieses relativ breiten in
diesem Abschnitt bereits schon besondere
Fähigkeiten über die du keiner zum Teil
nicht verfügen
ich habe mir noch mal das Spezial
angeguckt wo sie letztes Jahr zu Gast
waren am ersten Tag des Krieges und eine
ihrer Einschätzungen damals war dass es
Putin darum geht Kiew einzunehmen und
die Regierung zu stürzen das hat er ja
auch immer wieder bekräftigt dass er die
Regierung dort absetzen möchte auch
zuletzt in seinen Reden zum Jahrestag
aber es ist ihm bis jetzt noch nicht
gelungen was machen die Russen falsch
ich würde mal gar nicht sagen was machen
die Russen falsch weil ich würde erstmal
die die den Hinweis geben was machen die
Ukraine richtig die Ukraine verteidigen
ihr Vaterland ich sage das bewusst zu
akzentuiert weil dieses verteidigen ja
nicht nur in den Händen der Soldaten
liegt die seit 2014 gut ausgebildet
worden sind und offensichtlich auch der
kampfkräftig sind sondern es liegt auch
in den Händen der Zivilbevölkerung die
ihre Soldaten sprechen unterstützt und
die auch in vielen Bereichen sich
freiwillig zu den Waffen gemeldet hat
ich sag mal als eine Art Heimweh oder
Landschaft die grenzüberwachungsaufgaben
übernehmen und dergleichen mehr das
heißt es ist das Zusammenspiel
eigentlich im Sinne einer
Gesamtverteidigung auf der ukrainischen
Seite zwischen den Streitkräften auf der
einen Seite und zwischen der
zivilbevölker auf der anderen Seite das
hat man bei den Russen nicht gesehen als
zu Anfang Russland angegriffen hat hatte
man das hat man ja auch festgestellt
über nachrichtendienstliche Erkenntnisse
den Soldaten die aus Belarus kam gesagt
wir führen unsere Manöver jetzt in der
Ukraine weiter fort und dann ist ja
davon ausgegangen dass man
möglicherweise ich sag mal innerhalb
einer Woche oder noch weniger Tage
die Ukraine werfen würde und vielleicht
war die Vorstellung Putins und seines
nationalen Sicherheitsrates die das hat
davon ausgegangen ist dass die Ukraine
mit russischen Fähnchen am Straßenrand
stehen würden und den Befreiungstruppen
der Russen entsprechend zuwinken würden
und das war halt eben aufgrund der
Kampfmoral der Soldaten ukrainischen
Soldaten auf der einen Seite und auch
aufgrund der Einstellung der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung auf der anderen
Seite nicht der Fall das heißt hier
haben die Russen eine völlig falsche
Lage Beurteilung gemacht die
letztendlich dazu geführt hat das war
eine Situation haben wo sie heute ist
oder wie sie heute ist und wo die end
einzelne Stellung sind und ich würde mir
jetzt gesprächig einen Wunsch aus nicht
spekulativ ich würde mir wünschen dass
die Ukraine diese Angriffe die sie
damals begonnen haben im Sommer
überwiegend begonnen haben jetzt wieder
erfolgreich fortsetzen können auch
aufgrund der so hoffe ich verstärkten
westlichen Unterstützung
sagt Ex Nato-General Egon Rams und jetzt
muss ich doch noch mal fragen wo kommt
marktspielweg einen Autogramm von ihnen
also ich denke da noch drüber nach bei
mir sind einige Autogrammwünsche
angekommen ich formuliere das mal so und
ich habe bisher mich dabei
zurückgehalten weil
sowohl der Ukraine Krieg bei Ihnen aber
auch in anderen Sendungen oder bei
anderen Gelegenheiten beschäftigt mich
schon sehr intensiv und man hat mir vom
Deutschen Bundestag noch eine
Sonderaufgabe zugestanden nämlich als
Mitglied der onkelkommission für 20
Jahre Afghanistan und das ist auch eine
Herausforderung von daher kann ich
wirklich nur sagen ich bin mit Autogramm
sehr vorsichtig
alles klar dann wissen Star oder kein
Politprofi von daher ist es nicht nötig
wir freuen uns über ihre Expertise ob
mit oder ohne Autogrammkarte und die
Userinnen und User tun das auch vielen
Dank Herr Rams dass Sie bei uns einmal
mehr in der Sendung waren
ja es geht nicht nur um die militärische
Einschätzung sondern es geht auch darum
zu gucken wie es den Menschen vor Ort
geht das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste
dass man weniger über die Ukraine
spricht als mit den Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainern wie es ihnen im Moment geht
und das tun wir es gab Gebiete die haben
wir schon in der Sendung gesehen die
sind in den ersten Kriegstagen von
russischen Truppen regelrecht überrannt
worden Harke im Osten des Landes ist z.B
auch eine dieser Städte hier wird immer
noch gekämpft auch in den letzten Tagen
wurde hier russischer Beschuss gemeldet
und jetzt ist die Frage hier sehen wir
es hackiv im Osten des Landes nahe der
Grenze zu Russland wie lebt es sich dort
im Moment darüber sprechen wir gleich
mit Oxana michaluk Jennifer Girke stellt
uns die Ärztin aus Hacke vor und zeigt
wie ihr Alltag ist
seit Kriegsbeginn setzte Ärztin Oxana
Michael Schug jeden Tag ihr Leben aufs
Spiel um ihre Patienten zu behandeln
ihre Heimatstadt rakiv im Osten der
Ukraine wird seit zwölf Monaten immer
wieder heftig bombardiert
unsere Gespräche führte Oxana meistens
aus dem Bunker dort war die
Internetverbindung am stabilsten auch
bei Beschuss
[Musik]
wir sind gerade wieder bombardiert
worden es macht einem Angst aber man
gewöhnt sich dran
eine Rakete zerstörte ihre Wohnung die
Versorgungslage in der Stadt wurde immer
dramatischer
im Mai entschied sie sich zu fliehen und
fuhr bis nach Stade in Niedersachsen
sie wollte als Radiologin an einer
Klinik arbeiten ein neues Leben aufbauen
[Musik]
doch die Sehnsucht vergrößert als
gedacht wir treffen uns vor ihrem Haus
zum ersten Mal kehrt sie in ihre
zerstörte Wohnung zurück
überall hier waren solche Splitter
hier sie sind bis zum Schrank geflogen
die Splitter haben es bis dorthin
geschafft
und haben sich durch die Kleidung
gebrannt ein Wunder dass das Haus nicht
abgebrannt ist
draußen zeigt uns die 45-Jährige ihre
zerstörte Nachbarschaft jederzeit
könnten hier wieder Raketen einschlagen
das weiß auch Oxana aber zu Hause sein
sei wichtiger als in Sicherheit zu sein
tja und jetzt ist sie uns von zu Hause
zugeschaltet Oxana michalcuk wie ist die
Situation bei ihnen im Moment
die Lage ist stabil ich bin zu Hause mit
meinem Ehemann
und ich führe mein Leben als Arzt weiter
und auch als Ukrainerin
was merken sie von den Kämpfen gibt es
Bombeneinschläge gibt es Angriffe gibt
es Alarme wie leben sie damit
wird weite ich in bombardiert die
lebenswichtige Infrastruktur ist stark
davon betroffen
gestern wurde
unseren Infrastruktur auch getroffen das
können wir hören die Fenster machen
diese typischen Geräusche aber man kann
nichts dafür man muss damit leben
sie sind Ärztin welche Verletzungen
behandeln sie oder haben sie in ihrem
Alltag als Ärztin mit diesen
Verletzungen gar nichts zu tun
nein ich habe damit nicht zu tun denn
ich bin
Radiologe das heißt ich beschreibe
verschiedene Erkrankungen aber das sind
keine
Schusswaffen wurden oder ähnliches das
sind
Menschen die vor dem Krieg krank waren
und die auch jetzt krank sind
wie ist denn die Situation für Sie um
behandeln zu können haben sie alle
Geräte alle Ausstattungen alle
Medikamente die sie für ihre Arbeit
brauchen
[Musik]
ich bin für die Diagnostik zuständig und
wir haben alles was wir nötig haben
alles ist
betriebsfähig die Ärzte die ich kenne
haben viel an humanitäre Hilfe bekommen
und wir haben wir haben eigentlich genug
von allem
damit wäre auch die Frage von einem
beantwortet ganz kurz ich möchte nur die
eine Frage hier noch mit aufnehmen weil
ein User gefragt hat ob es aus dem
Westen auch Medikamente gibt nicht nur
Waffenlieferungen sondern auch
Medikamente offenbar hat es die in Form
von humanitärer Hilfe gegeben und bei
ihnen ist die Lage einigermaßen stabil
aber bitte sie wollten noch was sagen
ich habe
Freundinnen Ärzte die mit Kindern
arbeiten und die Lage mit Kindern ist
sehr schwierig meine Freundinnen sind
als Psychiater tätig
zurzeit gibt es sehr viele Kinder die
Hilfe brauchen und Kinder sind in einer
sehr schwierigen Situation
was die mentale Gesundheit angeht zum
Thema mentale Gesundheit gibt es hier
noch eine Frage über Youtube fragt ein
User ob es viele ukrainische Soldaten
mit Traumata gibt die von der Front
genommen werden müssen ist hier die
Frage also die von der Front
zurückkommen und traumatisiert sind
ich habe leider keine statistischen
Angaben dazu diese Frage kann ich leider
nicht beantworten aber sollte das
Interesse bestehen könnte ich im Militär
Krankenhaus Nachfragen ich bin da
persönlich leider überfragt
wir sehen hier die Bilder noch einmal
von
Kriegsbeginn wir sehen verschiedene
zerstörte Häuser wir sehen hier Bilder
aus Butter ein Jahr Krieg in der Ukraine
schreckliche Bilder die uns hier
erreichen und eine schreckliche
Situation für Sie vor Ort sie haben
lange ausgehalten sie haben dann
trotzdem versucht doch woanders ein
neues Leben aufzubauen und sie sind
wieder zurückgekommen das haben wir
gerade im Film gesehen können Sie noch
mal beschreiben was das mit ihnen
gemacht hat
ich musste die Situation akzeptieren
diese Situation hat das Leben ganz
völlig verändert man trifft
verschiedenen Entscheidungen man
versucht das man versucht was
Gutes daraus zu machen man bekommt nur
Erfahrungen und wenn man versteht dass
Jena Erfahrungen des Erfahrungen in
einem anderen Land dich nicht weit eine
nicht weiterbringen so kehrt man einfach
ins Heimatland zurück und setzt diese
Erfahrungen im Heimatland ein
hier schreibt einen User über Youtube
die Ukraine sind stark vielleicht macht
das ein kleines bisschen Mut was was
wünschen Sie sich für die Zukunft ein
Jahr nach Beginn dieses Krieges was
wünschen sie sich am allermeisten
wissen sie es gibt diesen Ausdruck wenn
das Leben weitergeht besteht die
Hoffnung solange es lebendige Menschen
gibt besteht die Hoffnung wir erwarten
alle den Sieg da gibt es keine
zweifeln es ist nur ein bestimmte
Zeitpunkt der kommen wird wir müssen
durchhalten
sagt Oxana michalcuk vielen Dank dass
Sie bei uns in der Sendung waren und
alles Gute für Sie
und damit sind wir am Ende unseres
Streams angelangt hier im ZDF sind wir
heute und morgen mit ganz vielen
verschiedenen Formaten für Sie da um den
Jahrestag dieses Überfalls auf die
Ukraine abzubilden Kanzler Scholz ist
zum Beispiel bei Maybrit Illner Marietta
Slomka hat die Ehefrau des ukrainischen
Präsidenten selensky interviewen können
sie können sich das alles anklicken auf
unserer Homepage bei ZDF heute und wir
werden versuchen morgen in dieser
Sendung einen Blick in die Zukunft zu
wagen haben wir ja heute auch schon ein
bisschen versucht und das werden wir
morgen vertiefen mit der Frage wie geht
dieser Krieg weiter und wann könnte es
wie Frieden geben also seid gerne wieder
mit dabei und bis hierhin vielen Dank
für eure Fragen und Kommentare tschüss